know what Islam is then we can know what
it isn't right
so we can know that Islam is a way of
life from the Creator it means
submission to the will of God this is
what Islam means and Muhammad peace be
upon him just like Jesus Moses Abraham
he was a messenger sent for you for you
for all of us but still I said he's a
messenger I just don't think he was the
last tree messenger you just affirms I
agree is a messenger you said that right
so let's go let's go before them would
you agree that there is nothing worthy
of worship if you're gonna worship
something would you agree that I
shouldn't worship anything except the
one who created me yeah you would agree
to that yeah used to worship false idols
man so you just beautiful so what you
just did was I'm sorry was your name
safe much respect and you are what's
respect so now you just actually
confirmed this belief when someone wants
to accept Islam what you just said I
agree that nothing should be worshipped
it's first negation for someone to
become a Muslim they have to negate that
I'm not gonna worship anything in
creation except the Creator then I'm
gonna agree that Mohammed is a Messenger
and this would automatically include all
the preceding messengers Moses Jesus a
Bri Abraham and all the other we believe
a beautiful see beautiful so now all
these messengers they came with the same
message not to worship Muhammad not to
worship money not to worship anything in
creation but to worship the one God in
Arabic Allah right this is what the the
message now someone will say all
religions are the same you see
[Music]
now we would kindly and with compassion
we would let people know that see Jesus
he didn't come a Christianity Moses
didn't come with Judaism they came with
submission to the will of God which is
Islam so now instead of worshiping Jesus
did you know that Islam is the only
non-christian faith which makes you have
to believe in Jesus it's an article of
faith if you don't believe in Jesus as a
messenger you will end up being in the
Hellfire according to us on denying
Jesus saying
any-any we say peace be upon him saying
any harmful guy that's the best thing
about Jesus the reason he got crucified
was because so he believed he was he
healed those born blind and leopards
when he gave life to dead but only with
God's permission you see we're on the
same page you see you see the only
parting of the ways is that people end
up taking him as a literal God see he
was a man he as God because he was at to
me in godly ways he was upon what are
you Muslim I have faith in God I don't
like to stick to one religion because I
think religion often has a tendency to
divide one another even though it's for
the same creator because the universal
creator kind of created one part of the
earth in one way and then another one
create another it's all the same not
only did you just confirm you confer
Mohammed is a Messenger you've confirmed
that nothing should be worshippers of
God you're actually wearing a modest
dress the hijab you're like wearing what
Jesus is mother
you actually have the attributes of one
who is a Muslim like after that
confirmation this is amazing look at so
what we say is that through all time
these messengers have said Jesus was
sent at his time Muhammad is just a last
and final messenger that's it but he's
not that's where that's where we have
two difficulties you're a messenger
right now therefore muhammad peace be
upon him cannot be the final messenger
because you are messaging so that sure
what we would say is now now what will
you say is if you have a potential book
where we say is the Quran is the last
and final revelation sent to mankind so
if you look at several times and maybe
it's a man but it's a woman he's
definitely still speaking I'm sure he's
still speaking to man to when you say
these people just don't yeah when you
say gods when you say God speaks to you
what do you mean can you explain that
like how I mean physically I mean
through symbols of life I mean there's
like so it's the universal I remember I
was telling you this the other day
wasn't it there was this one time where
I kind of went into a dreamlike state
that's basically it felt like for
instance there was no floors and there
was no rules and there was no car all of
a sudden I was in this this is a dream
this was a dream
and what happened is it a little
darkness at first and it felt like I was
floating through the universe and it
felt like I was so far away from Earth
that I was still like I could still feel
that I was still my conscious self yeah
but I was just away and then I could see
lights and there was these lights and
that looks almost like stars at first
but then I realized that they were
moving and they were moving in
particular directions and then I
realized it was like a city around me
but without the floor without the walls
without the ground and there was all
these people going on their tracks and
there was this Universal godly
consciousness that was trying to talk to
all of them through their mind but over
the course of time their people instead
of being at one with the peace of God
and accepting the truth of like the
message like a lot of them were getting
trapped in these devices and they
couldn't see they they could see but
they were being fed information and it
was blocking by the consciousness
yeah basically so this is a dream this
is the dream you could say maybe these
are like things that come to the human
being they're subtle signs right but
when we say God spoke to us what did he
actually mean when we dig down deeper
because of jami'a because in a jungle
yeah
and in this jungle there was vines
hanging down and there was like big
leaves and then there was this human and
he looks really familiar but he looked
like ancient me familiar
he looked ancient in the way that he had
always been he didn't look ancient in
the way that he was in pain like the
elderly back home he looked like he just
knew everything and he was like talking
but it wasn't in English it was just
like in this like universal peace and
everything you know what you know what
you know what beside look that's why God
Almighty he sent messengers out of his
love his mercy to guide us so now for
instance if you have the Quran and it
makes the claim that it is from the have
you ever read the Quran you've read bits
of it okay so now if we can affirm 100%
that this book is from the ground would
you say would you agree that we should
follow it if it's a book from the
Creator from the divine and it means so
if this book if we substantiate it with
evidence and proof not just blindly
accepting it if we Sasan she ate that
this book is from the divine and in that
book the book tells us that Muhammad is
the last and final messenger should we
accept that oh they have to go off
everything is I say - they have to go